on aimerait que latine bilan continue de
s'alourdir plus de 4 millions de cas de
kobe 19 ont été confirmés dont la moitié
au brésil le pays est le plus touché du
sous continent avec 2,2 millions de
contaminés il a enregistré un nouveau
pic hier avec plus de 60000 personnes
positives
on en parle avec mon direct sur arte
france avec franck gaudichaud est
professeur d'histoire et civilisation de
l'amérique latine
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors on vient de parler
du bilan avec une explosion de nouvelles
contaminations presque 68 cas au cours
de ces dernières 24 heures c'est un
bilan très lourd
oui tout à fait sensation que y compris
ces chiffres sont peu fiables car le
ministère ne communique pas et pas de
test massif au brésil donc on parle
plutôt de 80 mille mots sans savoir
exactement le le chiffre en tout cas en
moyenne à ce jour on est à environ mille
morts par jour donc le brésil est le
pays le plus touché au monde juste après
les états unis et nos vrais contexte
politique évidemment et que monsieur
molson arrow tout à fait catastrophique
alors on a parlé du président juste
après je voulais revenir avec vous sur
les grandes disparités aux régionales
qui avait au brésil au niveau des
personnes affectées par le corona virus
alors ce qu'on voit c'est que les zones
les premières zones est infecté qui
étaient autour d'eux notamment de rio
sao paulo il ya efforts de stabilisation
de l'épidémie et ça va maintenant plutôt
vers le sud le centre ouest où là il ya
une explosion du nombre de contagion et
aussi la grande préoccupation du moment
c'est pour les communautés autochtones
qui jusqu'à maintenant étaient assez
protégé là il ya aussi une
multiplication des cas de contagion avec
d'ailleurs une responsabilité de
certaines églises évangéliques qui
continuent à entrer dans les communautés
et les amène avec elle le
le virus alors on a vu un que donald
trump a récemment changé d'avis 20,8 au
port du masque
il commande une précommande des doses de
vaccin est-ce que jaillir bolt zone euro
qui était un peu considérée comme un des
chefs d'état sceptique face au co by 19
peut lui aussi faire volte-face pour
l'instant ce n'est pas du tout le cas
commencée le monsieur molson avait été
déclaré positif trois fois au kovy bluff
mais il est en quarantaine il continue à
dire que c'est pas très grave qui prend
la chloroquine et que tout va bien est
ce le ministre intérim qui a été nommé à
la santé c'est un général général pas
sous l eau qui est un incompétent
notoire il l'a reconnu lui-même en
termes de santé et donc au contraire ils
sont en train de bloquer la livraison
des masques ils m'ont estime qu'il ya
que 10% des crédits spéciaux alloués à
la lutte contre la pandémie qui ont été
versés pour l'instant alors que la
pandémie est galopante et il ya même
l'absence de bib raison des masques
prévu aux mairies au gouvernement
fédérer donc on est dans une logique de
déni et certains observateurs certains
acteurs politiques brésiliens parle
d'une politique génocidaire enfin
totalement irresponsable de qui conduit
à la catastrophe le douaisis
qu'aujourd'hui mon par nier justement du
général passe vélo qui affirmé que les
tests n'est pas nécessaire pour lutter
contre la pandémie comme on explique que
le président s'obstine comme ça dans
cette voie voilà la raison elle est
avant tout politique
jaya boissons à eau continue on en face
foulée la foulée de laisser cette
politique de dennis au plan de la
pandémie brossy de mobilisation d'une
base durs liés à l'extrême droite ils
essaient aussi de jouer une partie du
peuple entre guillemets contre les
élites contre les scientifiques mais le
coût de cette politique
certains disent que ces politiques l'ont
pris fascisante en tout cas d'extrême
droite est très très lourd on le voit
sur plan de la santé mais aussi sur le
plan de l'économie la crise économique
et qui est en train de s'abattre sur le
brésil va être catastrophique alors que
des pans entiers de travail et plaisir
sont des travailleurs informels dont ils
n'ont pas de protection sociale d'où
l'accentuation des inégalités avec le
collègue franck gaudichaud vous êtes
professeur d'histoire et civilisation
d'amérique latine merci d'avoir été en
direct avec mon sur rt france